[موسيقى]
من خلال عملي في مجال الصحه النفسيه على
مدار سنوات قابلتني كتير من الحالات رغم
اختلاف انواع مشاكلهم الحاليه لكن بيجمعهم
ان عندهم صعوبات في الماضي بالتحديد مشاكل
في مرحله الطفوله
يلاقي لها حل لما قعدنا ندردش كده انا
والاب والام فتره اكتشفت انه البنت بيتم
ضربها من لما كان عمرها سنتين
فلما سالت الاب والام هل تعتقدوا ان ممكن
يكون الضرب ده هو اللي مسبب ظهور الاعراض
دي على الطفله وما يكونش هي عندها مرض ولا
حاجه تكون دي مجرد اعراض بسبب
الاساءه اللي بيتم ممارستها عليه فاجئني
الاب وقال
عادي ايه يعني
ما كلنا كنا بنضرب واحنا اطفال ايه
المشكله انا زي الفل
قلت له طيب هل انت بتعاني من اي مرض زي
سكر او ضغط قال لي اه الاتنين قلت له هل
تعتقد انه ممكن يكون سبب الامراض دي ان
جهازك المناعي بسبب الاساءات اللي انت كنت
بتتعرض لها
احيانا كتير بنقول لاطفالنا اوعى تتكلم مع
حد غريب خليك هنا جنب ماما وماما ما تروحش
تسمع كلام اي حد ما تروحش مع اي حد طيب
كان العيله هي مصدر الامان ماذا لو كان
العيله نفسها هي مصدر الايذاء
هل يا ترى ممكن حاجه تعرضنا لها في
الطفوله منذ سنوات طويله
تفضل مقصره علي لو انا ما عرفتش اتعامل
معاها صح
وتاثر علي لحد لما اجي اختار شريك حياتي
وانا بتعامل معه
طب هل يا ترى
الاسلوب اللي احنا كنا بنتعامل به واحنا
اطفال
هنحب يكون نفس الاسلوب ان احنا نتعامل به
لما نكبر
الاسئله دي شغلت الجمعيه الامريكيه للعلاج
الاسري والزواج وقرروا ان هم يقدموا ورقه
علميه بتعالج الاسئله دي
باسم اليد الممتده
لصدمات الطفوله
جابوا ما يقرب من 7000 زوج وزوجه
بعضهم نشاوا في اسر سويه
وبعضهم نشا في اسر غير سويه وبعضهم واحد
منهم نشفوازين
وابتدوا يشوفوا
مدى هدوء الشخص
ومدى علاقته سواءه مع الطرف الاخر
اثبتت الورقه دي انه بالتاكيد زي ما انتم
متوقعين الناس اللي انا سعيد في اسره غير
سويه بتطلع مستوى علاقتها بشريك حياتها
متاثر
هي اصلا ما شافتش نموذج قدام عينيها زي
تتعامل بسواء
كمان اثبتت الدراسه دي انه مش بس مؤثر على
علاقتي بشريك حياتي ده كمان مقصر على
هدوءي انا مع زيتي
وبرضو زي ممكن اي حد يتوقع انه لما يكونوا
الزوجين نشا وفي بيئات غير سويه بيكونوا
اميل لانه العلاقات تكون مضطربه لكن لو
فرد منهم كده وفرد منهم كده نسبه انه
العلاقه تكون مضطربه بتكون اقل شويه
عن اي انواع الاساءه انا بتحدث انا ما
اقصدش هنا الصدمات بمعنى انه واحد خسرش
ماتش وهو بيلعب فزاعل وهو طفل او واحد
صياد في الامتحان او مره ام اتعصبت عليه
وقالت له لفظ مش مناسب او باباه مره زقه
وهو متضايق في مره انا هنا بتكلم عن ايذاء
طويل المدى المستمر غالبا اول ما بنقول
صدم الطفوله ايذاء اول صوره بتيجي على
بالنا الايذاء الجسدي
انه اب بيضرب ابنه او بنته ام ماسكه بنتها
بتضربها وبتعنف صح ده ايذاء وبيسبب صدمات
لو هو بيقام على مدى طويل مستمر لكن مش هي
دي بس المشكله في انواع ايذاءات تانيه زي
تعيير
زي وصمه انت على طول فاشل اصلا مدام انت
سقطت ما انا كنت متوقعه
او بالمقارنات انا نفسي تكون زي اخوك
الكبير انا مش عارفه اشمعنى انت في ولادي
اللي طالع كده
بيفضل هو طول حياته زي ما هنشوف كمان شويه
بيحاول يثبت العكس او بتسبب له هذه
الاساءات صدمه
في برضو اكتر من ده
الازاء عن طريق الهجر
ما حسسوش ان هو مشاف اصلا ولا كانه موجود
قابلتني حالات الاباء والامهات عمرهم ما
حضنوا الطفل او عبروا ليه بكلمات حب على
مدار السنوات لحد ما هو بيصل عمره 17 سنه
وما الى ذلك
هذا الايذاء بالهجر بعض الاحيان بيكون
اكثر ايلاما من الايذاء بالضرب لانه على
الاقل الهجر هو ساعات بيقعد يقول وانا
موجود ولا هم مش شايفيني اصلا هو انا
متحبش اللي بيضرب ده عارف ان هو بيتم
غالبا بيكون عارف ان هو بيتم ايقاع ايذاء
عليه غير اللي مهجور
برضو من احد الصدمات اللي احنا بنتكلم
عليها هنا ان يكون احد الابوين تم السجن
او هو مدمن او عنده مرض نفسي او الام
والاب انفصلوا كل دي اعراض تخلي النوم
ممكن الطفل ده يحصل له صدمه كبيره تفضل
مقصره عليه لحد ما يجي يختار شريك حياته
زي ما هنتكلم
في بقى حاجه ايذاء غير مباشر زي الاب
والام يكونوا في صدام ومشاكل وضرب احيانا
مستمر بس هو ما حدش بيلمس الطفل بس الطفل
بيتضرر
طيب هنا برضو هرجع ااكد انا بتكلم على
الصدمات طويله المدد منهج بيمارس على مدار
سنوات طويله
اثبت علميا انه بيغير كيمياء دماغ الطفل
نفسه جهازه المناعي بيقل الاطفال النشاه
في اسر غير سويه اكثر عرضه للاصابه
بالامراض من الاطفال النشاه في اسر سويا
طيب
هل يا ترى
حاجه مره عليها 15 سنه
طول حياتي من ساعه ما اتصدمت وانا صغيره
فضلت نايمه فجاه بقى افتكرت وصحيت اول ما
انا جيت اختار شريك حياتي لا مش هو ده
اللي بيحصل هي موجوده بس اما موجوده في
صوره واضحه ومباشره يا اما موجوده في صوره
غير مباشره
طيب واضحه ومباشره زي ان الطفل يظهر عليه
اعراض ان هو عنيف هتلاقي بيجي له استدعاء
هات مامتك وباباك بيحصل عندك مشاكل متوقع
عنيف منطوي او عنده ضعف ثقه بالنفس لكن
الجزء اللي انا حابه اتكلم عليه جزء غير
المباشر ان الطفل ده بيكون تم تعيينه
ومقارنته فيبدا هو من ساعه ما هو طفل
بيبدا يقارن نفسه بالاخرين كانه بيستمد
قيمه نفسه عن طريق مقارنته بنفسه بالاخر
ودايما ناظر لنفسه بدونيه من لما كان طفل
الطفل بيبدا يكون صورته عن الحياه وعن
نفسه من اول شخصين شافهم في حياته غالبا
بيكون الاب والام
فنظرته عن حياته نفسه بتتكون من خلالهم
فلو هو بيقارنوه شايفينه قليل ومش كافي او
مش شايفينه هيفضل طول حياته بيحاول يثبت
ده او يثبت عكسه
طيب
يا ترى ازاي ممكن ياثر على اختيار الشريك
حياتي
اما بياثر ان انا اختار
اختيارات نفس الشخص اللي كان بياذيني
بالظبط
ازاي يعني ممكن حد يختار جلاده من جديد
انا اتالمت من الشخص اللي اذاني ازاي هرجع
اختاره تاني بارادتي المره دي لما كبرت
معقول اه
كتير قوي بيحصل كده
ممكن عشان ده المكان اللي انا متعود
اتعامل به يعني ما تعلمتش انا غير اتكلم
بالانجليزي
فدي لغه صيني مش عارفها انا مش عارف حاجه
غير كده انا مش عارف اخش في علاقه غير نفس
النمط اللي انا نشات به وانا طفلي
ده اول تفسير
تاني تفسير انه ممكن الشخص ده نفسه
بيحاول يكذب من الجذب يعني نمط مشابه للاب
عشان
انا عايز انتصر المره دي هعيد نفس
السيناريو هقابل نفس الشخص المؤذي او اللي
كان هاجرني هختار وهنجذب ليه عشان المره
دي هثبت ان انت مش هتهزمني مثلا زي ما
ابويا كان بيقسوا علي وبيهزمني انا المره
دي هعيد نفس السيناريو هجيب شخصيه نرجسيه
او عنيفه بس المره دي انا هقف قدامك
وهصلحك او هاهزمك
او
يميل لاختيار نمط معاكس تماما
للشخص اللي كان بيتاذي منه زي
انه هو كان طول حياته مهجور من مامته
شايفاه ابدا ولا عمرها كانت بتعبر له عن
حبها سواء بالاحتضان بالكلام بالفعل
فيلجا ان هو يرتبط بواحده عندها مشاكل في
الارتباط
لزقه فيه بشكل مرضي
هي تعباه
تعب تعبان منها من كثره طلبتها ليه
بالاهتمام لكن هو بيحاول يعوض المعاناه
اللي هو عاشها مع امه بالهجر
طيب
دي الامثله بتاعه الاختيار
ماشي
ماذا لو بتاثر علينا كمان في تعاملنا مع
شريك الحياه خلينا نفترض اللي احنا مرينا
بالاختيار ده بسلام واختارنا صح انا مريت
بصدمه في الطفوله ورغم كده وما اشتغلتش
على نفسي ان انا ازيلها من حياتي يا
واواجهها واخترت صح هل هعرف اتعامل مع
الشريط بتاعي بشكل صحيح ولا لا
في نمطين
اما ان انا هميل ان انا
اعكس تماما الايذاء اللي كان حاصل كتير
جدا نمط ابوي مشهور واحد نشا في اسره فيها
عنف اسري شديد مدلع اولاده بشكل
بيستفز الاخرين سامح لهم يعملوا اي حاجه
ويتعدوا على اي حدود عشان انا مش عايز
اكون ابويا القاسي انا عمري ما هعنس
ابنائي ابدا مهما كان حتى ما بيحزمش معهم
او بيسعى الى تربيتهم بشكل سليم لان هو
عايز يعكس النمط ده وخلاص
او انه يعيد نفس السيناريو تقعد كده مع
شاب عنده مثلا 18 سنه يقول لك انا عمري ما
هكون ابويا ابدا اللي عمله فيا ده عمري ما
هكرره بس لما ارتبط هتشوفوا النموذج اللي
انا كان نفسي يحصل
بس قبله كمان عشر سنين
هتلاقيه بيعيد نفس النمط اللي هو كان لسه
بيحلف ان هو عمره ما هيعمله لانه عقله ما
شافش اي تجربه انسانيه خارج اللي هو شافه
في تجربته مع باباه ومامته ما حاولش يغير
مفاهيم وقناعاته عن العلاقات
طيب
برضو لو واحد او واحده نشا في بيئات
مهجوره
اما ان هو بيسعى انه يرتبط بحد زي ما قلنا
عنده ارتباط مرضي او هو نفسه يهرب من اي
ارتباط بعد ما بيخش في العلاقه كده بيحس
ان هو تحب وحب يقول لك لا لا لا مش سكتي
خالص انا هاهرب مع السلامه مش هقدر اكمل
ليه مش عارف انا مش مرتاح هو مش مرتاح
عشان عنده صدمه هو متعودش اصلا يتحب ما
تعودش اصلا يدخل في علاقه سويه فبيهرب
الطريق نحو التعافي او التحرر من الدايره
المغلقه ماشي
عيشنا في بيئه مستويه واسره صادمه نعمل
ايه
ادرك تقبل غير
اول مرحله هي عامله زي السلم كده في ناس
بتقف في اول مرحله كتير قوي بعد الوعي
النفسي في الفتره الاخيره اللي حاصله
بيدرك ايوه صح ايه ده انا انشقت بي اصادمه
اهلي هم المتسببين في كل المشاكل اللي انا
عايش فيها دي
قصروا معي كتير بفضل واقف هنا بعد ما تدرك
اثر اللي حصل بعد ما تشوف الجرح اللي عندك
ادخل في المرحله اللي بعديها مرحله تقبل
ان ده حصل ومش هيتغير
تقبل هذا الجرح كجزء من تجربتك الانسانيه
ما تخشش في علاقه عشان هي هتعوضني عن هجر
امي او هو هيعوضني عن ابويا القاسي محدش
مفترض انه يعوض حد عن طفولته ما تحطش
توقعات عاليه قوي من العلاقه فتفضل تطلب
من اللي قدامك انه يعوضك عن صدماتك في
الطفوله او دور مامتك وباباك هو مش مسؤول
عن كده هو دوره شريك بشاركك طريقك مش دوره
يعالجك
اتقبل ان الجرح ده جزء من تجربتي انا بقيت
كده عشان الجرح ده تالت نقطه اغير كلام
سهل غير تغير اعملها ازاي طيب اول حاجه
قلل من حجم
اثرها عليك
ما تحطش هدف عالي انه ازيل كل اللي حصل ده
لا مش منطقي ومش بيتزال بالشكل ده بيفضل
جوانا اللي حصل في طفولتنا بيفضل جوانا
لكن
هسعى الى تحجيم اثروا عليا في حياتي
الحاليه طيب
نخش كده على شويه
حاجات ممكن تساعدنا ازاي اغير
اول حاجه تامل نفسك جيدا حلل تصرفاتك اسال
نفسك يا ترى انا عماله اخش في علاقه وافشل
فيها واخش في علاقه ثانيه شبهها وفشل فيها
وعماله اقرر نمط هل انا حظي سيء قوي كده
ولا انا محتاجه اقف مع نفسي واراجع
علاقاتي عندي مشكله يمكن هل يمكن انا عندي
نمط معين عمال يجذب
الناس المؤذيين او انا بدخل في علاقات
اصلا هيسيبوني عشان انا عايزه اثبت لنفسي
ان انا طول عمري ما بتحبش وانا شخص متحبش
حلل تصرفاتك واقف مع نفسك
خلل يا ترى هو انا ليه حساس قوي
ناحيه الكلمه الفلانيه لما حد بيقولها لي
او شريكي بيقولها لي يا ترى ليه رد فعلي
بيبقى مبالغ فيه قوي في النقطه الفلانيه
اقف مع نفسك وحلل تصرفاتك جيدا
طيب ايه تاني ممكن يتعامل
تاني نقطه
غالبا الناس اللي نشقت في بيئه صادمه وغير
سويه ما يكونوش تعلموا اي حاجه عن التعبير
عن المشاعر لانه التعبير عن المشاعر
بيتعلم من طفي لما بيتولد لحد ما بيبقى
عنده عمره اربع سنين طيب حاول تعلم نفسك
طرق للتعبير عن المشاعر تعبير عن المشاعر
وتسميتها
هيقلل كثير جدا من ردود افعالك الغير
متوقعه والغير سويه
ابحث ازاي اعبر عن مشاعري بشكل سوي
ده اللي هيجيبنا للنقطه الثالثه راقب
الاسر السويه ولو شريكك اسرته سويه اتعلم
منه واتعلم ازاي بيتكلموا ويحلوا مشاكلهم
ازاي في حلول تانيه غير البيئات اللي احنا
اتربينا فيها مثلا
بيتناقشوا من غير تعيير من غير عنف من غير
الفاظ جارحه شوف بيتعاملوا ازاي لاحظ حاول
تعلم نفسك الحاجات اللي لم تكتسبها وانت
صغير
طيب
اكتب
الكتاب
جزء منها تنفيسي وجزء منها تفكير
انا بفكر كاني بفكر مع شخص اخر
كاني
بتعلم وسائل لتنظيم تفكيري بتساعدني ان
انا اطور من الحلول وما بتخلينيش اعيد
تاني نفس الحاجات اللي انا وصلت لها من
الاسبوع اللي فات كنت بفكر هو ليه ماما
عملت فيا كده ليه ابويا عمل فيا انا وصلت
فبكتبها فبنتقل للمرحله اللي بعديها
النقطه اللي قبل الاخيره
ان انا مطلوب مني اني راجع مفاهيميه احنا
اتكلمنا عليها في نص المحاضره انه انت مش
انت اتكونت عندك مفاهيم وانت طفل انت
مطلوب دلوقتي ان انت تقلع النضاره اللي
تكونت ابدا تساءل هل هذه النظاره اللي
اتكونت طول حياتي
مفيده هل سيداني في علاقاتي هل علاقاتي
جيده ولا لا
طيب في النهايه انا حابه اقول عامل نفسك
بالطريقه اللي انت كنت بتحب تتعامل بها
وانت صغير
تسامح مع نفسك خليك حازم مع نفسك
شجع نفسك
انا مدركه تماما ان مش مسئوليتك ان انت
نشات بيئه صادمه وغير سويه لكن الكوره بقت
في ملعبك دلوقتي دورك
انك تعالج هذا الجرح
يمكن فعلا مش بايدينا نرجع الماضي ونعيش
ذكريات الطفوله ونخليها جميله
لكن بايدينا ان نحاول نزيل اثر الذكريات
المؤلم ده من جوانا شكرا
[موسيقى]